people underestimate how much smarter
you can see them if you have 20 minutes
of preparation because if you practice
really hard you get better the only win
you get from not prepping and showing up
to the fight is that you appear to be
more naturally gifted and I would rather
be known for my work ethic than my
natural gift as an aside but you appear
to be more naturally gifted and then you
win by less than you would if you
prepared the only things that upset the
guys who are on the top of the mountain
is hubris there's really no reason that
the guy on the top of the mountain
should ever lose and yet history shows
us humans act like humans and so we lose
because of our egos and because it hurts
to say what if that person's better than
me